hi guys my name's Tamra's never seen and
this is Tamara chambers and I'm sick a
lot of things that are keeping me well
and I do have a box and this is a one
piece yesterday on my Twitter page I put
up a poll asking if you wanted me to see
Independence Day Groundhog Day
or Ferris Bueller's Day Off for the
first time Ferris Bueller's Day Off one
by quite a large amount secondly
Groundhog Day and then Independence Day
which I did not think was going to be
the case I thought people would want me
to watch Independence Day so pretty I
put makeup on for this it's a regret
that I'm having anyways I'm gonna watch
Ferris Bueller's Day Off which is I feel
like actually very perfect for my
situation because sick taking days off
from work and also watching a movie is
basically the only thing I can do at
this point in my life so oh okay all
right
I enjoyed that it was fun it was a fun
movie for sure I think it was a read
beginning he's faking sick obviously to
get his whole day off and I hate it like
watching this with bronchitis like fever
and he's like I'm so sick mother please
be a big faker and it's great especially
since his sister comes in and sees that
he's faking she hates him she's so mad
that he gets to stay home from school
she storms out of his room and it's like
that's it I want out of this family that
was the last drop on what I assumed was
a long list of things but that is the
last straw that makes you will leave
your family is a little extreme then you
jump to the school and the teacher is
calling out roll call and all I can
think of is the a a run schedule feel
and if you don't know what I'm
referencing then all I can say to you is
you've never seen that I can literally
not believe
you've never seen that so offensive to
me that you've never seen that what else
do people say to me did you grow up
under a rock or something you must have
come from an Amish household you for
never seeing that see what I did there
I'm being you guys it's not being the
commenter's six full circle
good job camera thanks Tamra you're
welcome Tamra stupid so Ferris called
Cameron who is his best friend and
camera is actually sick and he's like
come over here and pick me up said I
have a car blah blah and camera just
like I'm dying
like literally same I feel you there's
so many moments in this movie that I was
like same thing yeah see alright so
first of all the principal is the worst
obviously um dishes is reminding me of
my senior year of high school and I was
an awful student I knew that after high
school I wasn't going to go to a
traditional college I went to like a
two-year acting conservatory and I was
just watching this like I understand
this this as watching this as a high
schooler I would have loved this movie I
wrote the assistant Grace is lovely
though
no you know what no physical physical
skin I'm a dick but look at this pencil
though it's use the cat out of his head
so Ferriss somehow has access to his
school's computer through his computer
he uses this computer in incredible ways
considering it
giant Essen is just like the green
screen and like the detection of super
blocky like super old 80s computers also
their family must be well-off if he got
a computer for his birthday or Christmas
or whatever it was they were expensive
hey took me by surprise I wrote down
that he's popular and everyone has a
crush on him which I understand I was in
high school seeing this movie I probably
would have had a crush on him as well
but I had a crush on Inspector Gadget so
Cameron goes to Ferris his house and
they do this whole thing where they get
Sloan out of the school by calling the
principal and saying that Sloan's
grandmother died and then the
principal's like this must be Ferris and
then he tells Sloan's
father on the line that she needs to I
just you wish you asleep I'm struggling
so hard oh - you've all seen the movie
you know what happens so the whole thing
happens and the principal still thinks
affairs is behind it but they get Sloan
out of school for the day so it's like a
threesome they're all going out having a
great time the city fairs gets mad at
Cameron and like kicks them a little bit
and Cameron is like you don't hit me
that's not how this works we are friends
you can't take advantage of me even if
he does the whole movies but you can't
hit me though so don't do that it's
really cute and nice and seriously I'm
so sorry you're right you're right then
he goes and like manipulates him into
using his dad's Ferrari I was like oh
there was only a hundred of them made
and it was just I felt bad for Cameron
this entire entire movie Cameron and
Sloan were my favorite characters who
were on-screen the most also really
liked the sister and I also really liked
the hostess at the fancy restaurant one
getting asked somebody who lives in
Chicago it's really exciting to see
movies that are set in Chicago so this
was really fun to see them driving
around causing mischief in downtown
Chicago so they get a valet in a parking
garage five dollars to look after the
car meeting they paid for the car to get
stolen because honestly I just I really
thought that car was gone I can't
believe it wasn't gone it might have
caused less problems when it was gone
maybe in the end but what getting ahead
of ourselves now
so then cut to the mom checking in on
Faris and the whole rig of the dummy in
bed with the snoring going on and like
the lever as you open the door like move
him a bit it's just so brilliant as a
kid I would have just died over seeing
this but like that's so fun to watch it
was similar to when I watched The
Goonies I was like like rigs like that
are exciting and so cool I wish I would
have seen that aspect of this movie as a
child for sure I think broke down oh my
god the waiter is the best my favorite
character Faris continues to be the
worst followed around by his likable
friend and girlfriend who can't say no
to him so I guess I didn't like Faris
that much but I think like I said like
if I would have seen as a kid I would
have absolutely adored him but as an
adult I'm just like no you're kind of
just like a little rich jerk but that's
because I didn't grow up with it so then
they go from this really fancy
restaurant to a baseball game awesome
day so far and the principal is like
looking up but only what he's not on
screen at the baseball game is really
good and the principal asks the guy at
this he's at a food place at restaurant
food place as we like to call it here
and he's like what's the score and has
the cook and we cooks like zero zero
he's like who's winning she's like the
Bears which is so good I like that and I
know that people have quoted that before
right over my head so now I'm in the
loop y'all I made it started at the
bottom now we're here like here still a
lot long waiting chrysalis there's a
very cultured outing at the Art
Institute they keep running into the
Father the principal can't break into
Pharisees house the whole community is
rallying for Ferris in Chicago water
towers are everywhere it kind of shows
you where you are each neighborhood has
one so this would whichever neighborhood
just completely jumped ship it just
changes it just Save Ferris because
everything's he's dying he has so much
sympathy in this movie and he's just
like this little awesome jerk kid who's
he's getting away with oh here's
something I said holy did the
principal just crash a vase on the dog
he's trying to get in the house and the
dog starts attacking him and then the
next shot you see is just a base with
flowers and then the dog is like out of
it that's a dark new camera and it's
hilarious and his voices are amazing I
wrote so the sister comes home and
confirms her hunch that Ferris was in
fact faking it and she fooled it then
she finds the principal of her school in
the house she doesn't recognize him in
the moment because it's just an intruder
in her house and she just kicks the
out of him he's awesome but also how
creepy would it be to come home be
scared there's an intruder in your house
and find out what your principal unfit
school that's so creepy she's like
there's an intruder in my house and I'm
very cute
very alone and very protective of my
body those another moment of like shame
honestly then they get the car back from
the garage and I am just in awe they
didn't just take the car they just took
it out for a joyride which waxes the
mileage which the dad would I guess
definitely notice cuz I only had like
106 miles on it now it's at least 326 or
something which is a big deal but not
the like biggest of deals what Cameron
flips out so they take the car back to
kind of do some rewinding of the mileage
and that's not working and Cameron just
like you know what screw it I'm gonna
ruin the car
so he like left in the bumper and then
the car just gets ruined it's most
stressful seen in all of cinematic
history you can flat me on that no I
know it's not but it's really stressful
well I just don't like to get in trouble
and so I still don't have like a fear of
getting in trouble and so that scene
just stressed out so what verses into
this glass wall falls down a cliff the
car is ruined
the garage is ruined and then there's
this really weird like resolution moment
where Pierce is like it's my fault which
it is I'll take the blame and Cameron's
like no man I got it and there's this
really uplifting music going on by then
and I think it's supposed to make me
feel good like cool their friendship is
on good term great but it just makes me
feel like here you go again
will do she's getting away with
holy young Charlie Sheen also there is a
sister who I never got her name Jing Zhi
need me that's with it she is at the
police station because they brought her
in for making a prank phone call they
didn't believe that there was an
intruder in her house which is
ridiculous you have to believe women God
in a lot so the running home scene is
really awesome where he's trying to get
home before his parents get home so they
can't like check in on and that is
awesome he goes through so many houses
and backyards and in through houses was
very--it like a hygiene so he's at the
back door about to get in parents are in
the driveway and the principal comes up
is like I got you Ferris Baba and then
in a surprising turn of events the
sister saved him she's like oh come on
in Ferris also we found your wallet in
my house you I love the
demise of the preserves movie so he
makes it in bed right in the parents are
opening the door and you in that moment
figman what a cool day that was you did
so many things not in trouble you like
totally pulled off the
day off ever which is what this movie
was trying to do I don't know why he was
kind of redeemed in the end by getting
the sisters help I don't know why that
helped me like his character more but
for some reasons and she was like all
right you're cool I was like okay you're
cool the very end was super funny it was
like you're still here go home
done it's over the best thing a Deadpool
was parroting at the end of Deadpool I'm
confusing endings of credits
I don't know that very very hyped up on
dayquil
right now I have a lot of fun with this
movie and I think that some of the
characters are really strong I think
maybe the hype of this movie is just
like a little overrated
so I expected what are you still doing
here it's over get out of here go